I'm definitely wearing more clothing
than they'd be over right now today I'll
be trying an acupressure mat from Amazon
my upper back is real [ __ ] up I look
at multiple different screens and I do
get a lot of neck pain
I have something called degenerative
disc disease which sounds like way more
serious that it actually is I've had
chronic back pain for the last four
years I do suffer from moderate
scoliosis
which I've had for about 18 years I go
to Chinatown and I have them like really
just get into it
I've been in lots of different physical
therapy I've tried a prescription pain
medication I'd say I'm at like a 6 out
of 10
I've only been at work for two hours and
my pain level is already 70 so I'm
really hoping that this work I'm like so
open to trying things to relieve my back
pain factor this from Amazon is fine
with me because I love Amazon I trust it
I think
[Music]
I mean I'm playing my hand on here and
it's already stinging should I take my
shirt off or I imagine the end is where
I put my head and then I just kind of
laid out I want maximal effectiveness
from this high quality Amazon technology
it just feels prickly like a massage
like a bunch of fingers all together
going off my back kind of feels like
lying on a brillo pad
it feels got on my back it does not feel
good on the head it's like the best head
scratch I've ever had it's like getting
all up in the cranial areas
nothing can relax I'm curious to know
what this would be like with no shirt on
because I'd imagine it hurts a little
bit right seems like there's a lot of
little things on my head it's like
little ants crawling oh my god I don't
think I could ever sleep on this I don't
know why I started doing this this thing
here I think is really doing well
especially if you just move around a
little bit
wow it's really hurting my ear I do like
a little dancing I prefer laying down
not on this I've spent like thousands of
dollars on pain relief so for me 40
bucks is like up I'll try it I hope I
feel better when I stand up other marks
oh my I think it was the last thing but
yeah I'll seem concern now I feel like I
just took a nap I don't feel that
different you know a little more relaxed
a little more limber it feels like when
you sit on like a lounge chair with no
beach towel on it and you know that you
have like lines in your back I have that
but like times a thousand because it's a
lot of little holes I don't feel as much
neck pain my mobility is definitely
improve I probably won't try this again
just because for me and my specific back
condition I don't think it will be
helpful I think other means will be more
effective I think I purchase it what
dollar seems like not that much to pay
if you consider having to go and pay for
a massage or pay for an acupuncturist I
would spend my money on naked yoga
or like burritos cuz those are relaxing
as well I might still be trying to steal
the mat afterwards the day after I used
the mat I woke up feeling basically no
pain at all so I don't know if it was
just a coincidence or not but I might
change my mind about this mat
[Music]
[Applause]